more than 150 people die every day from
overdoses of opioids including fentanyl
but the latest weapon in this war could
save many lives a team of researchers
are developing an anti-fentanyl vaccine
eight news now anchor Kirsten Joyce
caught up with the head researcher on
the project to find out how this would
be applied
only two milligrams can can kill a
person depending depending on their
weight and so there's a Fear Factor Dr
Colin Hale is a research associate
professor at University of Houston and a
founding member of the drug Discovery
Institute there he and a team of
scientists have been working on vaccines
against drug abuse for quite some time
an anti-cocane vaccine and an
antimethamphetamine vaccine but when the
opioid epidemic started ramping up was
readily apparent that we had a big
problem the funding for those vaccines
pulled and switched to opioids what we
have right now is it working and we need
a new treatment strategy and that's
where the anti-sentinal vaccine comes
into play this anti-fentanyl vaccine
would be for people who have entered a
detox facility they would take it under
a doctor's care so if they have a
setback this is what would happen this
has vaccinated individual
does relapse they consume Fentanyl
the antibodies will bind to Fentanyl and
prevent it from getting into the brain
and they will not not feel any of the
effects and that will give them an
opportunity to get back on the wagon to
sobriety yeah I'm a person in long-term
recovery Giuseppe Mandel is the Director
of Business Development for there is no
hero in heroin Foundation it began after
his own brother could not overcome his
battle with opioids when he passed away
to a fentanyl poisoning and uh I just
wanted to uh
do something more with a purpose you
know Advocate more create more change he
says a vaccine like this can't come soon
enough it probably wouldn't be alive
today if fentanyl was around uh it's
killing a lot of people it scares a lot
of people and so uh yeah it's it's a big
deal I mean anything to Save a Life the
Department of Defense is helping fund
This research the Sentinel has been
weaponized by by certain countries and
so they whether they have used it
actually in the military theater is
unknown but it has been used as a weapon
that's why Dr Hale is also pushing for
other applications of the anti-fentanyl
vaccine
to protect our troops First Responders
and other individuals who are
inadvertently exposed to fentanyl all
eyes are on University of Houston in
your department I mean that's a big
responsibility well it's overwhelming
um as you can imagine
but you're ready we we know that there
are a lot of people that need a new
Therapeutics strategy to deal with his
heinous disease